we know developers don't like standing
still and want access to the latest and
greatest features in the tools they use
and that includes programming languages
with Android studio 3 though we're not
only shipping Kotlin as an official new
language for Android but we're also
making life easier for those of you who
prefer to code in Java by introducing
support for Java 8 language features in
the default tool chain starting with the
Android Gradle plug-in version 3 you can
freely use lambdas method references
default and static interface methods try
with resources and repeating annotations
on all Android API levels if you
previously switched to using the
experimental Jack compiler to be able to
use these features please note that
there are now many benefits when using
the default tool chain Jack offered more
restricted Java eight support that
worked only for API 24 and above it
wasn't as fast when compiling code and
it created problems for developers using
tools that depend on the class format
that's why we deprecated Jack and will
no longer support it in Android studio
and tools the good news is that
switching back is very simple just
delete these lines from your build file
if you're using one of the popular
third-party solutions for Java 8
language features you might find that
they lack some of the functionality of
the default tool chain such as being
able to seamlessly process libraries
that use Java 8 code if you want to make
the switch you'll have to remove retro
lambda or dexguard from your build
otherwise the built-in support will
remain disabled other than that make
sure you have the following lines in
build.gradle and that you're using at
least Android Gradle plug-in version 3
for important plug-in migration
instructions refer to our other video or
the documentation linked in the
description so now that you have
everything set up what can you actually
do with the new features lambdas are a
really nice short hand foundation for
implementing functional interfaces or in
other words interfaces that have only
one abstract method many times when you
pass a runnable or a listener to another
method you need all this boilerplate
just to run a few lines of code when all
you could write is this
Android studio lets you easily convert
between lambdas and anonymous classes so
you can learn the syntax quickly with
method references you can sometimes even
avoid creating a lambda by directly
passing a method with a correct
signature as a parameter use the double
colon syntax like this if you want to
put utility methods in your interfaces
you can now do it with a static keyword
moreover you can have methods with
default implementations that will not
require you to change any subclasses
when you add them to the base interface
try with resources is a great way to
deal with closable resources such as
files previously you had to be extra
careful to catch exceptions and close
any open streams in a finally block now
when you declare a resource in that try
block opening statement it will be
automatically cleaned up for you after
that block exits the new language
features are provided by transforming
byte code into a representation
compatible with other platforms a step
which we call the sugaring this is not a
backboard of Java eight packages and as
such many SDK restrictions still apply
for using newer api's like java.lang
stream in your code one last thing as
part of our continuing investment into
the tool chain with Android studio 3
we're introducing a new Dexter called d8
that is available for you to preview at
this line in your Gradle properties file
and the build process will use d8 for
converting class files to Dex bytecode
in our tests the eight compiles faster
and produces smaller files and can even
improve runtime performance as an app
developer you shouldn't have to make any
changes to your usual workflow when
using d8 however tool developers need to
be aware that d8 moves the de sugar step
after any custom bytecode transforms as
such your transformation tools might
begin to see Java eight byte codes when
using D eight and have to be made
compatible so have fun writing more
expressive code and please let us know
on the bug tracker if you run into any
issues when trying the new dax-ur and
check out the other videos about Android
studio 3 Dalal features
[Music]